bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre cet après-midi sur notre
antenne la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires l'ordre du jour du sénat a
été modifié pour que les sénateurs
puissent continuer l'examen de ce texte
cet après midi à la discussion reprend
sur la question des agences régionales
de santé leur création a été entérinée
la semaine dernière par les sénateurs
restent en débat la coordination entre
l'hôpital la médecine de ville et le
secteur médico-social tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle bonne séance à
tous l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de
la discussion du projet de loi portant
réforme de l'hôpital et relatif aux
patients à la santé et aux territoires
dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus à l'amendement numéro
1046 au sein de l'article 26 et pour cet
amendement numéro 1046 monsieur le mène
à la parole mais s'est imposé dans un
pays nommé ministre
cet amendement au projet de préciser que
secteur médico social ne se limite pas
aux personnes âgées et aux personnes
handicapées est important de mentionner
à l'effet des structures qui
interviennent en direction de personnes
confrontées à des difficultés
spécifiques qu'on accueille par exemple
des appartements dans le cas de la
coordination thérapeutique dans le lit
de halte garderie dans les cas rue sympa
le 9 nuls de l'article l 312 tirer 1 du
code de l'action sociale et des familles
mentionne les établissements ou services
qui assurent l'accueil l'accompagnement
de personnes confrontées à des
difficultés spécifiques en vue de
favoriser l'adaptation à la vie active
et l'aide à l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle ou d'assurer dès
prestations de soins de suivi médical
dont les centres de soins
d'accompagnement et de prévention en
addictologie
j les centres d'accueil d'accompagnement
à la réduction des risques pour usagers
de drogue et ce qu'ils ont dénommée lits
halte soins santé et les appartements de
coordination thérapeutique contre notre
amendement souhaite que ces différentes
structures puissent entrer dans le cadre
de cette hésitation
merci mon cher collègue quel est l'avis
de la commission
madame la présidente bonjour bonjour à
tout le monde et bonne journée à tous
cet amendement 1046 semblent satisfaits
alors on va attendre la réponse des amis
soit jugé pour se faire un avis complet
merci madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs effectivement
l'ensemble des catégories
d'établissements vous souhaitez insérer
et déjà prévues par la mention à ce même
alinéa de l'article l314 3 3 du code de
l'action sociale c'est un article qui
les citent tous expressément ce qu'il
fait que en fait votre proposition est
complètement satisfaite par la rédaction
actuelle
pourquoi je demanderai leur retrait
monsieur monsieur levens retirer votre
amendement
merci l'amendement 912 est défendu par
monsieur autres je suis hautain monsieur
fisher
monsieur autun s'ils veulent un
président que madame la ministre est
cher collègue
donc c'est très bien simplement nous
nous sommes réjouis de voir que
l'assemblée nationale avait comblé une
lacune en prévoyant que la rse serait
compétente pour créer ce fameux service
unique des aides à l'installation qui
était prévue depuis très très longtemps
puisque je crois que c'est le plan
démographie 2006 de votre prédécesseur
qu'il prévoyait
mais comme d'habitude le gouvernement
dans ce domaine n'a rien fait et il faut
donc que ce soit les parlementaires qui
prennent l'initiative
écoutez c'est s'est volontiers que les
parlementaires pression enfin est-ce que
ce que je voulais dire c'est que il me
semble que il aurait été préférable de
prévoir que les ars ne fasse pas que
contribuer à la création de ce service
mais mais mais prennent l'initiative de
la création de ce service c'est le sens
de l'amendement et nous faisons
simplement que substituer créé à
contribuer et nous ajoutons aussi
quelques mots concernant le concours
deco l'éthique et des collectivités
territoriales concernées car nous
pensons que ce guichet unique ne peut
être mis en oeuvre sans les
collectivités territoriales puissent que
vous savez que ce sont les collectivités
régionales ou locales qui mettent en
oeuvre ces mesures qui sont susceptibles
enfin qui sont créés pour faciliter
l'implantation des médecins dans les
zones sous médicalisées soudan s'y fier
d'ailleurs l'irdes en 2003 avait recensé
137 au total 137 mesures régionales où
le cas là est évident que pour s'y
retrouver
les étudiants aux besoins de ce guichet
unique donc oui au guichet une
mais nous souhaiterions que la rs presse
prennent une part plus importante dans
la création de ces de c2c guichet unique
avec qu'au cours des collectivités des
collectivités territoriales pardon merci
un chocolat est de l'avis de la
commission
merci dans la main présidente la
commission a jugé qu'on ne pouvait pas
contraindre les collectivités
territoriales a participé à un service
unique des aides à l'installation si
elle préférait agir indépendamment de la
rs pour notre toit de certaines aides
c'est pourquoi la commission a préféré
elle contribue plutôt à elle créé a émis
un avis défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement madame ministre
oui madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord salut je salue tous et toutes
ici en ce cette reprise d'ing aux
travaux même argumentation pour la
participation des collectivités
territoriales vous êtes tous ici les
défenseurs de ces collectivités
territoriales on ne saurait rien leur
imposer aux motifs de subsidiarité
il ya un deuxième point sur lequel je ne
suis pas d'accord avec monsieur autun
c'est que évidemment dès 2006 mes
services ont demandé aux missions
régionales de santé mrs de mettre en
place en concertation avec les
collectivités territoriales des guichets
uniques à disposition des professionnels
de santé pour qu'elle faisait justement
cet interlocuteur unique et bien entendu
nous reprendrons les missions des mrs
qui feront également partie des agences
régionales de santé j'entends certes
peut reconnaître certaines insuffisances
on veut pas dire que rien n'a été fait
je compte amplifier grâce aux agences
régionales de santé
ces missions de guichet unique qui sont
effectivement tout à fait indispensable
et la rédaction actuelle du projet de
loi correspond évidemment bien entendu à
votre volonté monsieur sénateurs c'est
la raison pour laquelle je suis non pas
défavorable mais disons votre objectif
est déjà satisfait monsieur autant
est-ce que vous maintenez votre
un amendement dit je vais retirer mon
amendement mais après avoir dit qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d'imposer quoi que ce
soit aux collectivités territoriales
mais simplement de faire en sorte que
elle participe avec le directeur général
de la rs au même titre qu'elle
participait avec les missions régionales
à l'élaboration de ces de ces schémas
vous remercie
nous passons maintenant à l'amendement
numéro 1156 rectifier que défend
monsieur barbier
oui merci la présidente mais chaque
collègue luminy mesdames les ministres
ou est ce cet amendement a pour but
d'une manière générale sont intervenus
déjà plusieurs fois ce que dans le cadre
de la sécurité de la qualité de
l'organisation régionale
les ordres des médecins pharmaciens
dentistes puisse être associée cette la
mise en place de cette politique d'une
manière j sont à peu près
systématiquement écartés on a réussi à
introduire la semaine dernière la
participation des professionnels de
santé
je crois que les ordres régionaux
peuvent avoir quand même un rôle à jouer
ne serait-ce que dans le respect des
codes de déontologie des uns et des
autres et cet amendement vise également
à compléter le l'utilisation des
produits de santé par les actes médicaux
et paramédicaux et au bon usage des
médicaments qui ne figure pas dans le
texte qui constitue quand même un
problème très important concernant
l'organisation de la santé régional
merci quelle est la ville de la
commission mais la présidente la
commission souhaite un retrait sinon
elle émettra un avis défavorable à cet
amendement car elle considère qu'il
n'est pas la mission des andes
professionnel d'avoir une mission de
contrôle technique mêmes armes à la main
ministre
oui effectivement c'est pas du rôle des
désordres d'avoir une d'avoir une
mission de contrôle technique néanmoins
je souhaite qu'ils soient associés et
sans reprendre exactement ce que dit
monsieur barbier je souhaite que son
souci de que la rs travail en bonne
coordination avec les ordres
professionnels soient prises en compte
chacun dans son rôle bien entendu c'est
la raison pour laquelle je vais proposée
par un amendement lors de l'examen du
titre 2 à l'article 19 ter je vais
proposer un amendement qui va prévoir
explicitement la consultation du conseil
de l'ordre des médecins par la rs sur
les sujets et questions qui relèvent de
ses compétences 1 alors donc si vous
pouviez retirer cet amendement au
bénéfice de ceux que je vous présenterai
dans quelques temps du moins je l'espère
aujourd'hui peut-être je vous en serais
reconnaissant alors pour ce qui concerne
le champ de compétence de la rs de chant
de veille de la rs couvre les produits
de santé dont les médicaments font
partie intégrante et de la même façon
les agences seront compétentes dans le
domaine des actes médicaux acception qui
recouvre aussi bien les actes pouvant
être fait par des médecins que par des
auxiliaires médicaux
donc la définition qui est donnée par le
code de santé publique couvre bien le
chant que vous souhaitez voir couverts
par les responsabilités des ars donc là
aussi si vous pouviez retirer des
amendes ans puisque nous cet amendement
puisque nous le satisferont un peu plus
loin
monsieur barnier oui compte tenu des
explications bien entendu je fais
confiance à madame le ministre en ce
début de semaine
je suis saisi 2
d'un amendement et d'un sous amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
pour l'amendement un numéro 879 soutenu
par monsieur désessard même la
présidente
mesdames les ministres sur le
responsable de la commission sur le
rapporteur chers collègues
donc il ya eu trois amendements de
retirer la donc quel va être le destin
de mon amendement un j'ai eu le plaisir
de découvrir un sous-amendement du
gouvernement je dois dire c'est la
première fois en depuis que je suis dans
cet hémicycle donc vraiment la semaine
commence bien on va dire
j'espère qu'il y aura un avis positif à
mon amendement et qu'il va recueillir
l'assentiment de l'ensemble de notre
assemblée aussi puisqu'il est si
important je ne vais pas tarder à le
présenter un jeu sous est inséré un
alinéa ainsi rédigé les agences
régionales de santé veille à assurer
l'accès aux soins de santé et aux
services psychosociaux des personnes
accueillies en centre d'hébergement
d'urgence
cet amendement propose de préciser les
missions et compétences de la rs en
matière d'offre de services de santé
afin de garantir l'accès aux soins des
personnes âgées accueillis en centre
d'hébergement d'urgence
chaque hiver les autorités sanitaires
lancent des appels d'offres pour
l'accueil des personnes sans abri
de nombreuses associations y réponde et
assurent l'accueil les repas du soir et
du matin et offre un accompagnement dans
la mesure de leurs moyens notamment pour
faire valoir les droits à la cmu et des
aux démarches administratives rassembler
les documents selon une étude de l'insee
de 2003 je n'ai pas trouvé d'autre
depuis
63 % des usagers de ces services dead
souffre d'une maladie grave ou chronique
je dis bien 63%
ces personnes très précaire souffrent de
pathologies liées à l'indigence et au
froid maladies respiratoires bronchites
chroniques asthme
les reculs aux affections du système
digestif maladies du foie et truc de
comportements alimentaires maladies de
la peau eczéma mycoses sur oasis il
souffre également de maladies
psychologiques récurrentes
un quart des usagers des services dead
souffrent de dépression et on dénombre
de très nombreux suicides les addictions
au tabac et à l'alcool font également
des ravages importants
toutes ces pathologies nécessite des
diagnostics professionnels d'autant que
certaines de ces maladies peuvent se
soigner comme le diabète ou
d'hypertension
mais nécessite un suivi dans la durée en
revanche l'évolution sans soin de ces
pathologies
outre les profonde détresse physique et
mentale peut conduire un état de santé
extrêmement dégradée nécessitant
nécessitant des soins beaucoup plus
lourd et coûteux et laissant parfois des
séquelles irréversibles
il nous sommes donc essentiel que les
ars est pleine compétence en matière
d'organisation de l'accès aux soins des
populations les plus précaires et les
plus fragiles de notre société c'est à
la fois indispensable sur le plan humain
et rationnelle du point de vue de la
santé publique
en ce qui concerne le sous-amendement du
gouvernement c'est un sous-amendement
qui vient préciser les catégories de
personnes considérées vivent en
situation de précarité d'exclusion et
qui recouvrent un champ plus large que
les seuls personnes accueillies en
centre d'hébergement d'urgence
en incluant l'ensemble des structures
d'accueil social débit 10 couches
sociales et des formes d'hébergement ou
de logement adapté
c'est donc un élément positif qui vient
renforcer les compétences des rs pour
mettre en place une politique de santé
publique en direction des personnes abri
des personnes sans abri je vais un peu
au delà
mais je voulais quand même dire que
chaque oeil avec beaucoup avec une
opinion très favorable le
sous-amendement du gouvernement merci
mais chaque collègue le sous-amendement
1318 du gouvernement
oui madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs comme vient de
le dire monsieur le sénateur des stars
d'abord lui dire que bien évidemment
l'amendement qui vise à préciser
effectivement l'accès aux soins des
personnes accueillies en centre
d'hébergement d'urgence montre tout
l'intérêt porté et que nous partageons à
la prise en compte de l'accès aux soins
des plus démunis dans le cadre des
dispositifs mis en place par cette loi
hôpital patients santé territoires et
l'organisation des agences simplement
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur de ce
soir au travers de votre proposition
d'amendement il nous a semblé utile de
ne pas exclure une partie des
populations en situation de précarité
c'est pourquoi dans cette dans ce
sous-amendement que nous vous proposons
est bien notre souhait est bien c'est
d'insérer effectivement à la place
d'accueillir en centre d'hébergement
d'urgence
les mots en situation de précarité ou
d'exclusion
accueillis dans les structures sociales
ou médico social ainsi que les lieux
d'hébergement où les logements adaptés
ce qui permettra de ne pas exclure une
partie des publics les plus en précarité
les plus en détresse de notre territoire
dans le cadre de cette politique porté
par roselyne bachelot moi même et bien
sûr partout le gouvernement voilà si
madame la ministre l'avis de la
commission celle rapporteur mais
l'amendement ils soient maintenant oui
les deux oui je vais les prendre un par
un de tabor l'amendement de monsieur
nécessaire le 879,6 est une
préoccupation qui est extrêmement
louable elle est couverte quand même par
les dispositions prévoyant l'élaboration
d'un programme relatif à l'accès à la
prévention aux soins des personnes les
plus démunies qu'on trouve à l'article l
14 34-1 du texte de loi page 123 pour
être précis et il est par ailleurs
impossible de préciser dans le détail
dans la loin toutes les missions des ars
surtout à cet article on donne déjà une
définition très cher
donc pour l'amendement du gouvernement
nous considérons la commission a donc
émis un avis défavorable à l'amendement
de monsieur gc ca 1 879 et elle
considère que l'amendement du
gouvernement le 13 18 qui illustre les
risques d inauguration qui sont jamais
complète et considère que par cet
article 14 34-1 il est satisfait
monsieur le président oui même la
présidente
je crois que l'amendement de notre
collègue nécessaire est important parce
que nous savons fort bien que il suffit
pas de voter une loi contre la lutte
contre la précarité contre l'exclusion
pour permettre véritablement l'accès aux
soins des populations les plus
défavorisées et je me souviens fort bien
avec valérie létard l'avoir accueilli
lorsque nous étions sur cette loi à lyon
et avoir visité des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence pour apprécier
les conditions dans lesquelles ceux-ci
d'une pas fonctionner les moyens dont
ils disposaient et on sait bien que
c'était l'exemple que nous avions eu la
plupart du temps il y avait dans le
suivi notamment de ces populations une
très grande difficulté parce qu' il
n'était pas constamment ouvert les lieux
l'accueil n'était pas constant et à
partir de là c'est un des problèmes et
je crois que à la lumière de la crise
qui explosent en voit naître toute une
série de catégories notamment de la
population qui se trouve avec des
difficultés nouvelles on a même vu
surgir notamment l'idée de pauvreté
laborieuse c'est à dire on peut très
bien avoir aujourd'hui des ressources
eh bien cela ne suffit pas pour vivre
dans des conditions dit et c'est un des
points qui méritent d'être repris et je
crois que là il y a beaucoup à faire
parce qu'au delà des discours il faut
des actes et ceux là et vient méritent
d'être prises en compte et je crois que
quand on voit par exemple notamment pour
les jeunes qui se trouvent confrontés à
de multiples difficultés bien la
ressource moyenne sera telle que 600
euros avec le rsa etc
donc ce sont autant de difficultés qu'il
convient d'aborder et de mettre dans la
loi d'insister bon monsieur le
rapporteur nous dit que ça y est déjà
mais moi je préfère voter l'amendement
de c'est ça merci monsieur cazaux
faisait partie aussi de l'expédition de
lyon avec guy et madame la secrétaire
d'état
sur un travail qui avait pas d'ailleurs
totalement était bien reconnu à l'époque
nouvelle somme que ça évolue
je dirais que l'amendement de notre
collègue nécessaire un pari excellent
parce qu'il est précis il précise quand
même les choses sous-amendé aph par le
gouvernement il précise bien les choses
et il l'est il les cibles exactement
dans leurs objectifs
alors que l'argumentation de monsieur le
rapporteur m'a paru assez faible parce
que alors fait référence à un article
assez généraliste à mon avis donc nous
serons sont favorables à cet amendement
est à ce sous-amendement et nouveau trop
mou merci monsieur désarmant de la
parole je suis échaudés par quand même
un certain nombre de médecins qui
refusent de prendre des malades qui sont
qui sont assez mûrs on sait très bien
que ça existe donc si ce n'est pas
réaffirmé qu'il faut faire quelque chose
vers les plus pauvres les plus précaires
c'est inquiétant parce que ça veut dire
que tout le monde le fait bien
aujourd'hui monsieur le rapporteur ce
qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas vrai 1
donc que ce soit réaffirmé comme
priorité ça me semble nécessaire
d'autant que je lis l'article alors
peut-être qu'un début de semaine j'ai du
mal à comprendre mais ça serait quand
même surprenant c'est vous dites que 14
34 un bon je trouve rien sur la
précarité l'exclusion donc je vais au 14
34 2 ou là je trouve quelque chose page
123 la page et emon et vous dites le
plan sera oui mais vous étiez déjà
trompé dans l'article 1 dans le numéro
bon peu importe le plan stratégique
régional de santé prévoit d articulation
avec la santé au travail la santé en
milieu scolaire et la santé des
personnes en situation de précarité et
d'exclusion
ce n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
c'est en articulation ça veut dire on
fait avec
alors que là on dit vraiment que les
agences régionales de santé ont un
objectif de s'en occuper et je reprends
les chiffres que j'ai développé 63% des
personnes précaires sont atteints de
maladies ce qui veut dire que c'est
utile pour ces personnes là et c'est
il aussi pour les finances puisqu'on
sait très bien que s'ils que si elles ne
sont pas soignés à temps
cela va coûter 5 10 20 fois plus cher
quelques mois ou quelques années plus
tard
donc c'est à la fois un argument
économique un argument social est un
argument humain et ça n'a rien à voir
avec le fait qu'il faut articuler dans
un plan stratégique c'est une
réaffirmation donc monsieur le
rapporteur
donc vous pouvez continuer effectivement
dans votre démarche de dire qu'on doit
pas prendre cette catégorie là avec
attention mais de façon spécifique mais
ce serait vraiment dommage
si le président abou dhabi nice mes
chers collègues j'ai bien compris et ses
agents de stars qu'elle est bonne
volonté mais le rapporte à raison car
même si dans la page 123 ceci il
apparaît qu'à travers le plan
stratégique régional de santé
il n'est pas moins vrai que ça concerne
au moins là l'ensemble des exclusions et
des précarités et des situations de
précarité à la verse votre amendement
voudrait dire quoi voudrait dire que
nous n'avons à prendre en compte cette
précarité que lorsqu'elle s'exprime à la
suite d'un hébergement en centre
d'hébergement d'urgence et la la c'est
notre véritable stupéfaction mais même
est alors le sous-amendement de la
ministre est à ce moment de génie
puisqu'il dit vous oubliez aussi les
appartements ou mais il n'y a pas de
précarité uniquement dans les centres
d'hébergement d'urgence ou dans les
appartements il y en a dans la rue
est-ce que par votre amendement vous
souhaitez dire clairement qu en aucun
cas il relèvera des ars le choix de
prendre en compte la précarité et
l'exclusion lorsqu'ils s'expriment en
dehors des centres d'hébergement bien
entendu que non mais bien sûr c'est pour
ça qu'il faut voter contre l'amendement
de mal heureusement dieu sait si
j'apprécie l'un de ses seins mais contre
son amendement qui irait à l'encontre du
but qu'il cherche à atteindre
donc je souhaite par pitié que jean ne
cessa retire son amendement ce qui
évitera de voter contre le
sous-amendement de la ministre qui
malheureusement ne nous donne pas
pleinement satisfaction
madame la ministre
effectivement en même temps je rejoins
complètement en fait l'amendement mais
même je pense que tout le monde partage
le souci effectivement de prendre en
compte les personnes en situation de
précarité maintenant maintenant si comme
vous l'avez dit il ne faut pas omettre
une partie des personnes qui sont en
situation de précarité ou d'exclusion
on peut peut-être à ce moment là précisé
en deux temps le sous-amendement pour
faire en sorte de faire ressortir donc
non seulement en situation de précarité
ou d'exclusion est particulièrement ou
notamment accueillis dans les structures
social ou médico-social pour insister
sur une partie de ces publics qui sont
effectivement dans des situations qu'il
est nécessaire de préciser mais là où
monsieur le président vous avez raison
c'est qu'il faut veiller à ce que dans
la rédaction ne soit pas effectivement
omise certaines personnes en situation
de précarité
peut-être que dans la rédaction nous
pouvons essayer de faire ressortir ces
populations qui sont les plus exclus qui
sont demandés ce type structures
d'accueil et l'hébergement d'urgence
en complément ou en tout cas en
spécifiant les choses et en marquant
l'intérêt porté sur celle là
maintenant voilà oui mais chez le
président à monsieur prise dragon le
rapporteur que je demanderai à la
ministre plutôt de s'arrêter après
exclusion
car il me semble que on doit prendre en
compte tous ceux qui sont en situation
de précarité ou d'exclusion
et pas de bien coup en disant notamment
ou particulièrement ceux qui sont
accueillis j'hérite particulièrement
ceux qui sont accueillis accueillis ils
ont dans leur malheur encore cette
chance
mais y en a qui le sont même pas donc
j'en ai tendance à dire notamment ceux
qui ne sont même pas accueillis dans des
donc voyez bien qu'il vaut mieux pour
éviter des erreurs de 2,2 des non sens
où des contresens s'arrêter purement et
simplement après exclusion dans le
sous-amendement de la ministre
oui je rejoins complètement le président
à bout en réaffirmant ici que depuis le
départ depuis que nous examinons cette
loin nous essayons de faire en sorte de
ne pas avoir des numérations
sachant qu'une énumération entraîne
toujours des choses qu'on oublie et ceux
qui sont oubliés il faudra revenir par
la suite de cl c'est pas évident donc
nous préférons être un petit peu plus
généraliste pour n'oublier personne que
d'aller dans libération profonde donc si
on mettait le texte on est sans
s'arrêter après ou d'exclusion le
ministre si cet amendement permet
effectivement après discussions et je
pense que vous avez raison il ne faut
pas omettre aucune
en tout cas aucune part de la population
en situation de précarité
donc si on peut effectivement modifié et
rectifier en tout cas le sous-amendement
pour faire en sorte que ça ne soit pas
le cas je pense qu'on satisfait à
monsieur nécessaire et on revoir la
rédaction proposée par le gouvernement
de la façon effectivement la plus
protectrice possible et en insistant
particulièrement sur ce que visait
monsieur de ce sahara qui me paraît
aller dans le bon sens c'est celui de la
mise en exergue d'une partie de la
population qui souffre plus
particulièrement encore en ce moment et
on voit bien là tout l'intérêt du débat
et du travail parlementaire
merci si madame la ministre je vais
faire voter sur le sous-amendement du
gouvernement de rectifier
comme vous l'avait proposé ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption voudront bien
levé la main
rectifiez n'est ce pas le ceux qui sont
contre il n'y en a pas absents sion donc
l'âme le sous-amendement et d'accepter
leur maintenant l'amendement 879 de
monsieur désessard pour le maintenez
monsieur d'aisé ça oui bien bien je fait
voter je fait voter sur votre amendement
ceux qui sont favorables vont bien
exprimé à l'unanimité
c'est très bien je vous remercie et nous
passons à l'amendement 1327 présenté par
le gouvernement
ce sont les mêmes participants au débat
que mercredi dernier le pont de
l'ascension et à peut-être fait que
certains ont besoin d'avoir la mémoire
un tout petit peu rafraîchi mais
beaucoup se souviennent effectivement de
la rédaction du président à bout qui
avait fait la quasi unanimité pour
l'article elle me 434 11 et l'article l
1434 11 prévoit que le programme
régional de gestion du risque pour
lequel rs est compétente
ouvrez les guillemets reprend les
actions nationales et comprend des
actions régionales complémentaires et il
faut évidemment que cette rédaction soit
reprise à l'article l 1432 deux donc
c'est un amendement de cohérence avec ce
qui a été voté mercredi dernier
merci l'avis de la commission favorable'
meuse alors je fais voter sur une lampe
à l'explication de vote je vais voter
sur cet amendement ceux qui sont
favorables exprimeront en levant la main
ceux qui sont contre par l'abstention et
les donc adopté et l'amendement 209
rectifiée présentée par madame paient
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre cet amendement est un
amendement de coordination à
l'amendement qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité à l'article 3 et qui prévoit
que les contrats d'établissement
comporte non seulement un volet social
mais également un volet culturel
depuis plusieurs années les nombreuses
expériences ont été menées dans les
établissements de santé en matière
culturelle l'ont été sur le fondement de
la convention signée entre le ministère
de la santé et le ministère de la
culture le 4 mai 1999 qui définit un
programme culture à l'hôpital et qui a
posé les premiers jalons le protocole du
10 janvier 2006 signée entre les deux
ministères en français cette dynamique
ce programme s'est concrétisé par des
conventions signées entre les arracher
les draps des programmes ont également
été mises en place avec des
collectivités territoriales comme l'a
expliqué déjà ma collègue catherine
morin dessailly
ces dispositifs ont montré tout leur
intérêt et pris leur place dans le cadre
du projet d'établissement de nombreux
hôpitaux
aussi nous semble-t-il utile de préciser
par cet amendement que les nouvelles
agences régionales de santé en lien avec
les draps pourront dans la continuité de
ce que faisait les haïr à jouer un rôle
d'impulsion et d'initiative
c'est le sens de l'amendement que ses
cosignataires vous demande d'adopter
mercy un chat collègues l'avis de la
commission
madame la présidente la culture a déjà
été introduite dans l'article 3 au
niveau des ses pommes dans le cadre des
contrats
donc nous considèrent la commission a
considéré que cet amendement de son
offre et eefje était satisfait la
demande de retrait ou ce serait un avis
défavorable dans la mesure où on l'a
déjà mis dans l'article 3 la ministre
oui oui madame scemama sénatrice
effectivement c'est comme l'a dit
excellemment le rapporteur nous avons
satisfait cette volonté à travers
l'examen l'examen du titre 1 et
d'émissions et d'émissions de l'hôpital
accès à la culture dans les hôpitaux
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
primordiale je pense que de réintroduire
cette cette démarche au sein des ars
aurait sans doute un effet de confuses
entre les missions des différents des
différents services de l'état et la
gestion sous forme conventionnelle entre
les ars et les dracs de ces initiatives
me paraît être le niveau suffisant pour
satisfaire votre votre démarche
et c'est pour cette raison que je serais
très heureuse que vous retiriez votre
amendement puisqu'il est satisfait de
façon très précise à l'article 1a le
titre à deux c'est l'article 3 je crois
4 3 ou 4 3 c'est bien l'article 3 du
titre 20 madame paillé oui je remercie
madame le ministre
et c'est vrai que nous avons été à
l'unanimité un article 3 que les
contrats d'établissement contenteraient
bien un volet culturel
pour autant nous n'avons pas précisé les
modalités
cela reste bien entendu la
responsabilité de chaque établissement
malgré tout il nous semble important de
garantir la qualité des interventions
culturelles prévues aussi pour ce faire
il nous semble utile de préciser en
s'appuyant sur le résultat très positif
des expérimentations menées depuis dix
ans que la mise en oeuvre de ce volet
culturel devra pouvoir être accompagnés
par les ars en association avec les drac
et les collectivités territoriales qui
le souhaitent et qui dispose elle même
de savoir faire nous souhaitons donc
vraiment que l'article l 14 31-2 qui
porte sur les missions confiées aux ars
puisse inclure la réflexion sur les
politiques culturelles
je souligne que la rédaction de cet
amendement ne fait pas peser une
contrainte vraiment extrême sur les dix
acteurs puisque sont utilisés les verbes
souhaite encourage favorise donc
j'insiste sur l'importance de cet
amendement qui permettra de garantir le
sérieux et le professionnalisme des
interventions dans le domaine culturel à
l'hôpital c'est pourquoi cet amendement
qui est vraiment très cher au coeur de
madame morin dessailly
je vais le maintenir merci vous
maintenez votre amendement très bien
alors je vais faire voter sur ce
l'amendement présenté par madame payet
qui qui a recueilli 2
avis défavorable du gouvernement et de
la commission ceux qui sont favorables à
l'adoption présentée par mme adam payet
lèveront la main faut compter là
merci et ceux qui sont ceux qui sont
contre l'amendement de madame payet est
adopté nous avons maintenant deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 8 176 rectifiée
présentée par monsieur désessard oui je
vais le défendre rapidement parce que le
l'amendement présenté par monsieur le
maine il ressemble beaucoup
et donc au choix du rapporteur de dire
lequel il préfère un cet amendement que
je présente a pour objet de généraliser
les registres des cancers en confiant
aux agences régionales de santé le
pilotage de leur mise en oeuvre
en coopération avec les observatoires
régionaux de la santé
en effet la mise en place d registre de
candé cancer est une promesse du plan
national santé environnement est
également une préconisation du groupe de
travail santé du grenelle de
l'environnement
merci l'amendement numéro 1021 présentée
par monsieur le même bien écoutez c'est
le frère jumeau de celui qui va être
présentée par notre collègue de ses
seins
moi je rappellerai simplement que
seulement en 2003 selon le souhait du
canada république la lutte contre le
cancer était érigée en priorité
nationale de santé publique ce qui
aboutit d'ailleurs à la mise en oeuvre
d'un plan de premier plan quinquennal et
en mars dernier vous avez vous même
madame le ministre présenté les
principales mesures du deuxième plan de
lutte contre le cancer qui ont été
élaboré à partir des recommandations
remises par le professeur grünfeld le 27
février 2009
donc nous souhaitons fortement que cette
mise en place d'un registre régional des
cancers a chargé d'effectuer le recueil
en continu et exotique exhaustif des
nouveaux cas de cancer pour chacune à rs
de notre territoire soit un moyen pour
conduire évaluer et améliorer la
politique va être conduite dans ce
dans le cas de ces pathologies
extrêmement importantes à traiter
merci qu'elle est la ville de la
commission sur ces deux amendements
oui madame la présidente je sens que je
fais pas faire plaisir à mon collègue de
ses stars ni d'ailleurs aux collègues le
maine mais je vais là répondre
simplement que la mise en oeuvre des
registres des cancers
c'est fait déjà et c'est fait par
l'institut de veille sanitaire en
collaboration avec l'inserm a aucune
raison de changer d'organisme pour faire
cette veille
donc j'ai un avis défavorable aux deux
amendements
l'avis du gouvernement oui effectivement
l'objectif de monsieur décès seraient
largement couverts nous avons
actuellement 15 registre généraux qui
ont pour objectif de couvrir 20% de la
population métropolitaine les registres
du cancer ou une expérience forte ancien
de l'épidémiologie voulait compléter ce
dispositif sous l'égide des ars en
développement notamment une surveillance
dans les départements non couverts mais
nous mettons cet objectif actuellement
en oeuvre par l'institut national de
veille sanitaire qui met en place un
système multi sources de surveillance
des cancers et il permettra de
surveiller l'émergence des nouveaux cas
dans chaque région et autorisera des
comparaisons entre chacune de ces
régions
alors vous souhaiter d'autre part que
les observatoires régionaux de la santé
appuient ces registres du cancer
les aurès évidemment contribuer à mettre
à disposition des informations générales
sur la santé en recherchant des données
aussi bien au niveau régional qu'au
niveau infra régionales pour autant ils
ne sont pas chargés des registres du
cancer et n'interviennent pas dans leur
mise en place et je crois qu'il ne faut
pas de confusion des responsabilités
alors l'amélioration de ces registres du
cancer va faire l'objet de mesures très
précises dans qui vont être inscrites
dans le plan cancer qui va être publié
dans quelques
en quelques semaines le plan cancer 2009
2013 s'il s'avérait mais ce n'est pas
sûr du tout qu'un certain nombre de ces
mesures mérite un fondement législatif
nous les évidemment nous les inscrits
riom dans la future loi de santé
publique puisque la révision de celle ci
est inscrite dans les dents dans nos
futurs travaux mais pour l'instant le
dispositif de progression que vous
souhaitez est d'ores et déjà à l'oeuvre
merci monsieur des essarts vous
maintenez votre merci monsieur le mène
de même merci beaucoup
nous arrivons à l'amendement numéro 920
que des formes monsieur autun si le
présidente
la ministre est cher collègue cet
amendement vise pour contribuer à mieux
équilibrer la répartition des médecins
sur le territoire à s'inspirer de ce qui
a été mis en place pour les infirmiers
libéraux pour ces derniers un arrêté
ministériel à déterminer les critères
communs permettant de définir les zones
surdenses de telle sorte que les
missions régionales de santé puissent
mener des études au niveau local afin de
déterminer les zones surdotées
l'obligation réciproque de régulation de
l'offre dans les zones surdenses a fait
alors l'objet d'une circulaire adressée
à tous les préfets de département ainsi
qu'aux directeurs des heures calmes
il a été précisé par la ministre de la
santé et la secrétaire d'état chargée de
la solidarité que ces nouvelles mesures
seraient prolongées sans la moindre
difficulté puisque la prise en charge de
la globalité de cette régulation allait
être confiée aux missions régionales de
santé avant que les agences régionales
de santé se voit confier en plus de la
définition des zones surdenses le soin
de veiller à sa mise en oeuvre
en lieu en lien pardon avec les acteurs
locaux
la disposition que nous vous soumettons
n'est que le miroir adapté aux médecins
des dispositions qui ont été prises
quand les infirmiers libéraux
il ne s'agit pas là d'une mesure à
proprement parler répressive elle vise
plutôt à pondérer la cadence des
installations en zones sur denses en
permettant ce faisant aux zones
sous-dotées d'être un peu mieux loti
nous sommes en effet à la croisée des
chemins puisque l'on observe d'une part
que les médecins privilégient les
installations selon des critères tels
que la proximité de la capitale est en
général des centres villes
l'ensoleillement où la proximité de la
mer au détriment des zones rurales et
des zones urbaines sensibles
d'une part les projections de
l'observateur national de la démographie
des professions de santé montre que le
potentiel démographique des médecins
commencent à baisser à partir de 2008
car le nombre de départs à la retraite
sera plus important que le nombre de
nouveaux diplômés jusqu'en 2025 si
l'offre de soins est appelé à se
contracter comme le rappelle le député
bernier dans son récent rapport
pour la mission d'information sur
l'offre de soins sur l'ensemble du
territoire la demande de soins risquent
en revanche de croître avec le
vieillissement de la population et la
forte prévalence des maladies chroniques
notre amendement vise à prendre en
compte cet avertissement et à le
traduire rapidement en mesures concrètes
ici en là même la présidente la
commission a émis un avis défavorable à
cet amendement présenté par le groupe
crc spg
par cohérence avec les positions prises
par elle même qui ne prévoit pas de
soumettre à autorisation administrative
l'installation de praticiens libéraux la
comparaison avec les infirmières ayant
eu lieu il faut simplement rappeler que
des infirmières l'ont fait par voie
conventionnelle et non pas par voie de
la loi donc c'était un avis défavorable
sur l'amendement l'avis du gouvernement
effectivement cet amendement est tout à
fait substantiel et il est un des points
de fracture entre nous ça s'éteint
peut pas nier que ce soit un amendement
tout à fait tout à fait fondamentale et
qui oppose bien qui fait une véritable
ligne de démarcation entre la majorité
et l'opposition
effectivement nous sommes très attachés
à la liberté d'installation des
professionnels libéraux
nous allons trouver dans quelques
instants je l'espère au titre de toute
une série de mesures pour équilibrer la
démographie médicale pour pallier la
désertification la désertification
médicale et la désertification plus
largement en professionnel de santé par
des mesures qui portent aussi bien sur
les études sur l'installation sur les
modes d'exercice sur le développement
des coopérations entre professionnels de
santé
nous allons aussi revenir sur la
création d'un corps de médecins
boursiers qui seront à la disposition à
l'ama des agences régionales de santé
pour permettre de venir étoffer les
zones les zones sous denses mais tout
cela dans le respect de la liberté
d'installation
le rapporteur a très bien dit que les
mesures qui avaient été acceptées par
les infirmières l'avait été dans le
cadre de la négociation conventionnelle
et en échange d'ailleurs de prise en
charge substantielle et dead extrêmement
substantiel sur le plan financier par
pour les infirmiers et infirmières
si dans le cadre de la négociation
conventionnelle et médecin souhaitait
aller dans cette voie
ma foi le gouvernement on verrait bien
la façon dont aboutirait ces
négociations conventionnelles
oui le président fait remarquer que ce
serait étonnant mais je ne laisse je
laisse faire cette observation
in petto si je si je puis dire en tout
cas c'est un avis défavorable
et c'est un avis j'allais dire
philosophiquement défavorable
il y a avant de procéder au vote est ce
qu'il ya des explications
monsieur case où je crois que cet
amendement
effectivement et est très important on
ne peut pas passer sous silence et le
balayer d'un revers de main
paradoxalement je m'excuse auprès de nos
collègues
grego terre on peut pas au détour de
l'amendement on peut pas au détour d'un
amendement décidé de quelque chose
d'aussi important
nous vous en conviendrez je crois que
tout le débat se fera certainement au
titre 2 à l'occasion de la démographie
on a quand même des moyens
madame la ministre le rapport bernier je
crois que c'est vous qui ont fusillé
état ou surtout nous a quand même donné
pas mal de pistes et je crois que les
entretiens nous aurons pu avoir les uns
les autres
autant avant les avec les asociaux
nationale des étudiants en médecine que
d'un terne
on nous a donné aussi la vie des jeunes
pas seulement de la csmf qui est planté
sur son conservatisme habituel donc je
crois que il faut qu'il y ait un débat
la ministre
là-dessus et il faut que le débat soit
plus riches
à mon avis que ce que vous nous proposez
parce que ce que vous nous proposez
ce sont quand même des pis-aller ce sont
des des processus d'attentes ou d'appels
comme vous voudrez mais voulait renvoyer
à 2012 pas ce sera plus facile monsieur
abou le sait bien aussi peut-être de
régler les problèmes en 2012 et
certainement pas au début de l'année
mais après ce que vous savez et bien que
de les régler aujourd'hui donc je crois
qu'il ya un véritable problème de
démographie
il faut en parler et il faut essayer de
trouver des solutions et je crois que
l'on ne pourra pas rester sur les
propositions de son fait
sauf à décevoir grandement nos
concitoyens et certainement aussi
un grand nombre tous ceux qui ont de la
difficulté aujourd'hui dans pas mal de
département a trouvé le médecin de
premier recours que vous investi que
vous avez institué la et car matière de
premier recours
très souvent ce sont les médecins de
dernier recours qu'ils essayent de
trouver et en vain parfois merci
monsieur autun oui on a le présidente
on va pas anticipé effectivement sur le
débat qui aura lieu nécessairement au
titre 2 mais je voudrais quand même dès
maintenant fait remarquer à monsieur le
rapporteur qui s'en remettaient à la
négociation conventionnelle pour régler
ces problèmes que jusqu'à présent dans
ce domaine et de l'envié à d'autres la
négociation conventionnelle a échoué bon
on a eu l'occasion je crois à l'occasion
d'un amendement déposé par monsieur
vasselle qui l'a retiré de parler
vaguement de cette fameuse négociations
sur la sur le secteur optionnel un qui
contrairement à ce que vous avez indiqué
madame le ministre n'a pas été commencé
il ya quelques mois qui a été commencé
il ya bientôt cinq ans et qui est
complètement enlisé comment pouvoir
aujourd'hui faire confiance à la
négociation conventionnelle pour régler
les problèmes de l'importance de cela à
savoir l'inégal l'illégalité dans la
répartition territoriale de nos de
l'offre de choix et les dépassements
d'honoraires qui ne sont pas le sujet de
cet amendement bien entendu mais je
crois que le premier point c'est que on
ne peut plus faire confiance à la
négociation conventionnelle et qu'il
faudra bien un jour ou l'autre et le
plus tôt serait mieux que le
gouvernement dans ce domaine prenne ses
responsabilités en malheureusement
contrairement à ce que vous avez promis
au fil des débats sur les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale
d'année en année vous deviez si la
négociation conventionnelle davoudi sais
pas
faire oeuvre législative or vous n'avez
rien fait sur le plan législatif vous
continuez à vous en remettre à une
négociation qui n'aboutit pas alors
l'autre point que je voudrais faire
remarquer c'est concernant le la liberté
d'installation des médecins alors vous
en faites l'alpha et l'oméga de votre
politique
je pense que malheureusement ça ne
suffit pas pour répondre à la demande
des patients la la la liberté
d'installation des médecins se fait au
détriment des patients puisqu'il est
avéré aujourd'hui que cette liberté un
que vous avez défendu bec et ongles et
d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup de mérite
puisque vous avez derrière vous la
profession dans son ensemble
donc vous l'avez défendu mais il faut
reconnaître que ce qui a régressé
c'est l'accessibilité géographique est
tarifaire de tous à des soins de qualité
et ça ça a régressé sanaa je tiens loin
de s'améliorer c'est en train de
régresser donc de ce point de vue là
tout ce que vous avez essayé un a échoué
d'entrée
non je crois que le moment est venu de
remettre en cause une politique qui a
échoué
il suffit pas de dire je suis attaché à
la liberté d'installation des médecins
pour faire en sorte que tous les
patients puissent être pris en charge
comme il le devrait
1 c c'est évident donc il va falloir il
va bien falloir un jour essayer de
remettre en cause les fondements de
cette médecine ambulatoire à savoir la
liberté d'installation et le
conventionnement un systématique
quel que soit le lieu d'installation et
enfin pour terminer je dirai que ce qui
est et ce qui est possible pour les pour
les poids pour les infirmiers ce qui est
possible aussi pour les pharmaciens les
pharmaciens il s'installe bien dans des
zones complètement complètement déserte
1 et ils ont que je sache des familles
et il n'y a pas de problème majeur il
n'y a que les médecins qui ont des
problèmes donc une raison je ne sais pas
laquelle nantes toujours est il que je
trouve que dans ce domaine là on peut
pas se recroqueviller sur une défense
intangible de la liberté d'installation
ça me paraît complètement dépassé par
les besoins de la population aujourd'hui
si un château avec monsieur leclerc
la parole madame la présidente madame la
ministre va pas faire effectivement un
départ avant l'heure sur l'installation
des médecins généralistes mais je
voudrais simplement dire
alors en ce moment du débat que c'est
vrai nous sommes attachés à cette
liberté d'installation et nous sommes
bien convaincu que ce ne sont pas des
mesures autoritaires et coercitives qui
amèneront les jeunes médecins sont
exercés dans des zones défavorisées car
en amont il y a quelque chose qu'il ne
faut pas oublier même si vous étiez
coercitif chers collègues c'est que vous
allez voir se tarir l'évocation de
médecins comment des jeunes vont faire
une dizaine d'années d'études pour se
voir obligés d'exercer dans des zones
qu'ils ne trouvent pas attractif pour
des raisons que l'on connaît
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
aujourd'hui via des statistiques nous
avons jamais temps une médecin mais
aujourd'hui un jeune médecin attend 10
ans avant de s'installer il n'y en a que
30 % des diplômés qui vont s'installer
en médecine générale quel que soit le
lieu géographique réfléchit c'est
pourquoi les jeunes hésitent à aller
dans un exercice libéral dans un
exercice qui a ses contraintes et qui
n'offrent pas les garanties qu'ils sont
en droit d'attendre au bout de vingt
années d'exercice professionnel
puisqu'il y a le temps de formation est
ensuite le temps de remplacement et
c'est donc le deuxième aspect c'est
l'aspect conventionnel c'est le seul qui
soit possible mais pourquoi pourquoi
aujourd'hui il y à un tel blocage dans
le système conventionnel
interrogez-vous quand l'autre jour on
évoquer les honoraires un juste prix
elle bien oui mais de quel droit 2 quel
droit quelle est la légitimité des
partenaires sociaux de la cnam pour
avoir des positions aussi bloqué sur des
tarifs qui ne correspondent à aucune
prestation chirurgicale pour
un certain nombre d'entre elles je vous
avais dit mais bien sûr faut quand même
être raisonnable quand j'évoquais 300
euros une hernie discale brut
regardez ce qu'il reste en êtes vous
allez vous embêter de prendre ses
responsabilité d'effectuer ces actes
techniques pour un salaire que en tant
qu'élu vous ne voudriez pas tant
qu'indemnité alors n'exigez pas des
autres ce qu'on n'est même pas foutu
d'avoir pour nous et c'est pour ça que
je dis qu'aujourd'hui le système
conventionnel il est bloqué parce que
vous avez un partenaire qui campent sur
des positions qui sont totalement
irréalistes et jade elle est posée la
question de quel droit
merci monsieur barbier
oui madame la présidente chers collègues
une âme les ministres je crois
qu'effectivement on aborde une question
qui n'est peut-être pas lieu de discuter
à cet endroit mais moi je suis quand
même très surpris de des travaux de
notre assez haute assemblée qui d'une
manière systématique vers anvers une
profession dont on sait qu'elle ya une
pénurie extrême de médecins qu'on essaie
de corriger par diverses mesures de
vouloir prendre des sanctions ou des
mesures incitatives mais enfin très
coercitives serait excessivement
dangereux alors moi je suis madame le
ministre un problème philosophique de
base nous aurons à nous prononcer mais
c'est quand même un petit peu curieux
que dans cette haute assemblée
on est d attaque aussi violente comme
celle qui a été lancé par une collègue
socialiste la semaine dernière qui a pu
dire que les internes et les chefs de
clinique coûtait à la société quand on
sait le travail qui est exercée dans les
hôpitaux publics
parce si c'est proprement scandaleux
d'entendre ça et puis j'ajouterai que
même madame le ministre faudrait dire à
vos services qui vous donne des chiffres
exacts puisque la semaine dernière vous
avez avancé que les médecins que les
praticiens hospitaliers avaient un
salaire de 7350 euros brut
je vous signale qu'il s'agit du salaire
net et que le salaire brut de 5800 euros
en fin de carrière c'est à dire après 25
ans d'activité hospitalière et que pour
celui qui entre dans la carrière de
praticien hospitalier le salaire net est
de 3200 euros
alors je crois qu'il faut ramener les
choses à leur juste propos et que dire à
vos services qu'ils vous donnent des
renseignements exacts je peux vous
donner les décrets que vous avez pris
concernant cette affaire-là
les primes sont accessoires sont de 400
450 euros par mois que vous pouvez
ajouter
effectivement pour les praticiens
hospitaliers
je veux bien vous concédez ses 450 mais
entre 7350 brut et le net
22 % de charges sociales ça ne fait pas
c'est simplement un rectificatif que je
pense il fallait faire merci un chat
collègue monsieur le président fischer
moi je suis très heureux que notre
amendement suscite cette discussion mais
je ne laisserai pas passer ce qui a dit
dominique leclerc parce que c'est trop
facile de mettre sur le dos de la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie et de
trouver à travers la politique menée par
la cnam et bien les maux auxquels nous
sommes confrontés que les médecins sont
confrontés et c'est bon la négociation
conventionnelle
on sait bien et ça je les répéter
plusieurs fois on sait bien que dans cet
amendement d'appel sur l'offre notamment
et de telle façon que tous les
territoires puissent se voir et
permettre doté de deux professionnels de
santé véritablement impliqué que les
patients les plus démunis ceux qui sont
les plus défavorisés feu compass dont on
parlait de l'exclusion
bon moi je ramène toujours mon quartier
des minguettes
mais c'est comme ça et joie bien des
quartiers qu'ils ghettoïse et bien
l'inégalité d'accès aux soins
est en train de grandir de se creuser et
que ça c'est un des points fondamentaux
et puis par rapport notamment à la
négociation conventionnelle
bon c'est bien quand même que c'est
madame la ministre qui décide de tout
elle décide de tout et notamment en
termes de politique tarifaire bon pour
participer avec un certain nombre de mes
collègues au petit déjeuner qui sont
organisées par la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie
il y a le tuteur moi je l'appelle le
proconsul sanitaires c'est à dire
monsieur van roekeghem je le lui ai dit
et on sait bien et on sait bien que
monsieur van roeckeghem et bien dans les
négociations conventionnelles avec les
médecins je prends une part par exemple
pour passer la consultation de 22 à 23
euros
eh bien elle est conditionnée notamment
aux réductions de dépenses et notamment
au bon vouloir de la ministre dans la
bachelot s'est pas autre chose et il y a
toujours des moments privilégiés qui
feront que telle ou telle politique
tarifaire qui est absolument aujourd'hui
aller est ce qu'on peut dire cela est
attisée et bien fait qu' il y à un
mécontentement chez les professionnels
de santé
tous les professionnels de santé parce
que non non on leur tape pas dessus
on les fréquente nous sommes des malades
en puissance
nous y allons régulièrement et qu'est ce
qui vous le disent et bien notamment les
chirurgiens dont vous faites partie
monsieur barbier et bien ouais donc non
mais
vous mourrez compte et c'est pas une
attaque personnelle mais que les tarifs
ont été bloqués et sont bloqués et qu'à
partir de là il ne s'en est il
c'est sous jacent est bien c'est que la
politique de dépassement qui permettra à
un certain nombre de professionnels de
vivre décemment
alors certainement que le problème de la
réactualisation des politiques
tarifaires est posée mais qu'en même
temps
eh bien il faut pas faire payer à la
cnam et surtout aux patients aux
familles et bien des dépenses qui ne
doivent pas être qu'ils devraient être
assurés par la nation et par la
solidarité nationale
c'est un des problèmes si un chat clegg
s'il n'y a pas d'autres explications de
vote
je vais mettre aux voix l'amendement
présenté par monsieur autun le groupe
communiste amendement qui a recueilli un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
avons la main ceux qui sont contre
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 1050 que défend monsieur le
maine et si même le président c'est un
moment un patio neil que celui que l'on
vienne voir on ne dira jamais assez
l'efficacité d'un système de santé
repose sur l'organisation de l'offre de
soins curatifs mais aussi sur la
capacité à agir en amont pour la
présence par la prévention
or nous savons notre approche de la
santé et les moyens n'est que nous y
consacrons privilégie largement les
aspects curatifs au détriment du
préventif
bien trop souvent passées au second plan
cette vision de la santé ne va pas sans
conséquence et vous le savez car si l'on
ne peut nier que la médecine soigne de
mieux en mieux et c'est bien l'on doit
bien aussi reconnaître que notre pays
est marqué par un niveau de mortalité
prématurée il ya des facteurs en partie
évitables
cet amendement que nous présentons a
pour objectif de demander aux agences
régionales de santé de répertorier
l'ensemble des associations qui effectue
les actions de prévention santé publique
afin de pouvoir éventuellement faire
appel à elle dans le cadre de ses
missions en matière de prévention et
d'éducation thérapeutique du patient en
effet de plus en plus d'associations
travail sur les questions de prévention
en santé publique
il serait donc judicieux pour que les
ars et répertorie pour les impliquer
dans certains programmes ou de
coordonner leurs actions
merci
l'avis de la commission donc la
commission a émis un avis défavorable à
l'amendement présenté par le groupe
socialiste estimant qu'on ne pouvait
imposer aux ars de procéder à un
inventaire exhaustif des associations de
prévention dans intervenant dans leur
ressort même s'il est évident évidemment
souhaitable qu'elles puissent coopérer
avec elle c'est un avis défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement la mu même avis
que le rapporteur s'il n'ya pas
l'explication de badges et fait voter
sur cet amendement ceux qui sont
favorables voudront bien levé la main
ceux qui sont contre il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 1053 que défend monsieur de
dénis madame la présidente mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues
la question de l'accessibilité aux soins
est bien au coeur de cette réforme je ne
ferai à personne ici le procès de
vouloir la négliger or si cet aspect
dépend non seulement de la démographie
médicale
la répartition géographique des
professionnels de santé sujet qui mènent
et évoqué de leur accessibilité
financière pour l'usager le temps de
parcours on est également une condition
discriminante et essentiel c'est
pourquoi cet aspect l'accessibilité aux
services de santé doit expressément
figurer au titre des missions de
l'agencé régionale dont la création
poursuit cet objectif principal les
compétences transversales de lagence lui
donneront une vision étendue de la
question des transports qui corrélé avec
la carte des services de santé doit
permettre d'opérer une répartition qui
tienne compte des besoins de l'ensemble
du territoire
cet amendement s'inscrit au surplus dans
la ligne droite de celui qui a été
adopté pour l'article 14 l'assemblée
nationale article 14 11-11 qui indique
que en termes de proximité
cécile doit s'appeler doit s'apprécier
en dix ans et en temps de parcours
convient de rappeler que de récentes
enquêtes ont montré l'augmentation
alarmante des renoncements aux soins
particulièrement de la part de personnes
les plus vulnérables
les ars doivent être un outil de lutte
contre cet état de fait est celui
proposé on constitue l'un de
l'amendement et réaliste dans sa
rédaction et sa proposition il propose
donc de fixer des durées maximales
d'accessibilité et propose que les
agences contribue donc on assurer
l'effectivité je dis bien contribuer
chaque collègue l'avis de la commission
madame la présidente l'amendement
présenté par le groupe socialiste
propose donc comme l'a dit entre les
deux ni de fixer les durées maximum
d'accessibilité
évidemment c'est une mesure qui est
extrêmement difficile à appliquer parce
qu'on se demande quels sont les critères
que nous devons prendre pour fixer ces
durées maximum d'accessibilité est ce
que sont des critères de géographie des
critères de locomotion des critères en
fonction de l'offre de soins des
critères en fonction de la pathologie
ça devient extrêmement difficile pour
pas dire impossible donc la commission a
émis un avis défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement oui si je si je
comprends à la suite du rapporteur
qu'effectivement le maillage de l'offre
de soins doit s'exprimer en fonction de
de topologie de durée de parcours pour
assurer un maillage le plus le plus
efficace est de plus en proximité
possible il est évidemment impossible de
le traduire d'une manière législatives
pour les excellente raison que devient
que vient de donner le rapporteur
différence de climat de topographie de
moyen de locomotion
mais bien entendu les ars intégreront
cela intégreront ce critère dans le
maillage territorial qui sera de leurs
responsabilités donc pour cette raison
un avis défavorable bien messieurs de
ligne et merci malin présidente
je regrette cette argumentation que je
ne comprends pas bien je ne veux pas
pourquoi on ne prendrait pas en compte
cette notion qui est absolument
fondamental aujourd'hui qui est celle du
temps de parcours et je voudrais citer
un autre exemple s'énerve et non aucune
aucun rapport avec la santé mais dans
l'accessibilité par exemple à des
services publics comme les bureaux de
poste il est tenu à la fois content des
kilométrages des distances et aussi des
temps parcours que cazaux oui c'est
quand même assez curieux d'avoir comme
argumentation de refus on ne sait pas
comment organiser la faire donc c'est
défavorable
c'est très curieux comme logique en fait
nous savons très bien particulièrement
qu'en milieu dans les milieux ruraux
il ya des temps d'intervention notamment
dans les périodes de garde notamment la
deux
une partie de la nuit puisque c'est
celle où le samu intervient seul souvent
et bien où manifestement certaines
personnes en milieu rural n'ont pas la
chance de pouvoir survivre
un accès aigu comme c'est le cas dans
notre secteur comme un milieu urbain
il n'y a pas de raison que ces milieux
soient défavorisées dans mon département
peut-être spécifique madame la ministre
en sérieuse grande département et bien
il y à des secteurs ou dans cette
deuxième partie de la nuit
il faut 25 à 30 minutes au samu pour
accéder à un malade
or en 25 30 minutes vous avez beaucoup
de pathologies et où manifestement le
samu et interventionniste les
internautes ce qui interviendront
arriveront trop tard donc ça vous serez
très possible d'instituer un temps moyen
alors c'est vrai qu'un institut un temps
moyen monsieur le rapporteur
et oui eh bien il faut se donner aussi
des moyens
il faut se donner aussi des moyens et
c'est vrai que avoir un seul centre samu
au centre d'un département très grand et
ne pas se donner les smur correspondants
mais sur 5 août un petit peu mais ne pas
sonné l'exclure correspondant qui
permettrait de compléter l'action de sa
mule est bien évidemment évidemment on
ne règle pas le problème
donc on tombe dans l'impossibilité et on
dit comme monsieur le rapporteur
c'est pas possible ou c'est trop
compliqué donc c'est défavorable
je trouve que c'est une solution trop
facile et hautain
merci présenter je trouve que cet
amendement est bienvenue et par
conséquent nous le voterons je voudrais
signaler pour illustrer la la la
démarche de nos collègues socialistes
dans le rapport de marc bernier
il était précisé que cette durée 1 ne
devait pas excéder trente minutes donc
dans ce rapport on fixe et bien une
limite au-delà de laquelle on ne pouvait
pas imaginer que les soins pouvait être
dispensés dans de bonnes conditions donc
je pense que il faut avoir à la pensée
7,7 durée pour imaginer qu'on puisse
adopter un amendement qu'un amendement
comme celui-là ci est ce qu'il y à
d'autres explications de vote non je
fais oui oui merci je voudrais donc
soutenir effectivement c'est un moment
simplement pour dire maintenant
l'occasion de développer tout à l'heure
quand le collègue passion va présenter
ses abonnements cas particulier de la
guyane
également on veut dire que si ces trente
minutes en guyane à l'intérieur du puits
du territoire c'est une heure
quelquefois comment je vais utiliser les
hélicoptères
c'est le lendemain et le premier chu se
trouve à la martinique ces deux heures
de vol dont je crois qu'il est bon à
l'instar d'ailleurs de ce qui existe au
niveau des secours par les sapeurs
pompiers
on peut déterminer un taux moyen est
effectivement il faudrait dès lors
développé une politique également de
moyens
merci il n'y a plus d'explications de
vote je fait voter sur cet amendement
ceux qui sont pour son adoption voudront
bien laver les mains
ceux qui sont contre
à l'abstention l'amendement n'est pas
adopté le mille trous amendement 1328
présenté par le gouvernement
madame la ministre
oui mais la présidente madame les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur c'est à
nouveau un amendement de cohérence
ensuite aux textes que nous avons voté
mercredi sur la rédaction de l'article l
1431 2 l'article 1435 4 en effet prévoit
expressément que la rs alloue des
crédits du fonds d'intervention pour la
qualité la coordination des soins le feu
je me fixe que vous connaissez bien du
moins ceux d'entre vous qui suivent la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale puisque ce levier financier
n'était pas explicitement confié à la rs
dans l'article l 1431 de que nous
examinons il convient par cohérence de
prévoir les modalités d'attribution du
fisc à la rs et c'est un levier
évidemment totalement indispensable dans
le cadre de sa mission dans le cadre de
la mission d'organisation qui confiait à
la rs en particulier on peut citer mais
c'est pas exhaustif pour les maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires
donc c'est un amendement de cohérence
par rapport à nos votes précédents la
commission oui madame madame la
présidente de la commission a émis un
avis de sagesse étant donné que ces
dotations dont parle d'un ministre était
attribuée par la mission régionale de
santé que remplace les ars à qui
reviendra d attribuer par ailleurs le
texte prévoit également les compétences
de la rs en matière de contrôle c'est le
petit d'edu de bulles de l'article l
14,31 diva 2 ne semble donc pas utile de
compléter le texte par cet événement et
de faire référence au fixe déjà
mentionné dans l'article sur la
contractualisation d'appel 130 convient
de rappeler dans le texte de la
commission
c'est à la vie de sagesse merci je ne va
pas monsieur vasselle
le président je m'interroge sur la
pertinence de la totalité de la
rédaction du texte ou le rapporteur
le rapporteur ayant émis un avis de
sagesse on considérant que tout l'aspect
contrôle n'avait pas forcément sa place
dans cette danse et alinéa donc la
question que je pose il faut qu'on aille
jusqu'au bout du raisonnement pour être
complètement en cohérence avec les
dispositions de l'avoir adopté
antérieurement
est ce que le rapporteur propose un
sous-amendement à l'amendement du
gouvernement où est ce que le
gouvernement envisage de rectifier son
amendement pour tenir compte des
observations faites par le rapporteur
parce qu'effectivement va se poser
ensuite pour l'exercice du contrôle les
moyens qui seront mises à la disposition
de la rs pour assurer ces contrôles
déjà nous considérons que la cnam
dispose de moyens parfois insuffisant
pour exercer ses missions contrôler s'il
faut envisager des transferts de
personnels de la cnam vers les ars pour
assurer ses missions contrôle qu'est ce
qui restera à la cnam pour exercer ses
missions contrôle pour les actions de
gestion du risque au niveau national
donc j'aimerais être crois qu'on a
besoin de bien comprendre l'articulation
qui va se mettre en oeuvre je pense
qu'il serait utile que madame le
ministre puisse nous nous éclairer sur
ces points de telle manière à ce qu'il y
ait aucune ambiguïté dans l'application
des textes de moment venu entre les deux
acteurs la cnav d'un compte et au dakota
et qui doit exercer des missions
contrôle et puis les ars qui devront
également exercé des missions de
contrôle
comment vont se compléter ses actions et
comment éviteront nous des détentions
des concurrences éventuel entre les deux
acteurs elle mise
non je pense ce que les tensions ne sont
pas à craindre je parle également le
secrétaire général jean marie bertrand
et là au banc et mène ces négociations
avec les différents échelons de
l'assurance maladie
bien entendu actuellement les personnels
qui sont chargés du contrôle de ses
actions et de la mise en oeuvre du fixe
seront évidemment affectée aux ars dans
le cadre des affectations de personnel
qui se partage entre entre l'assurance
maladie il ya absolument il ya
absolument aucun souci dont les missions
de contrôle seront effectivement assurée
par la rs merci pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je mets au voile
amendement du gouvernement ceux qui sont
favorables lève la main ceux qui sont
contre abstentions l'amendement est
adopté l'amendement 913 que présente
mais que des formations au teint maâlem
dont immoral c'est bon là merci madame
la présidente mesdames ministre mes
chers collègues la rédaction proposée
par cet article 26 visant à procéder à
la réécriture de l'article 1432 1 du
code de la santé publique précise que
les agences régionales de santé organise
la veille sanitaire
l'observation de la santé dans la région
recueille et traite les signalements
d'événements sanitaires
il dispose également que les agences
régionales contribuer à l'organisation
de la réponse aux urgences sanitaires et
à la gestion de la situation du risque
notre amendement vise donc à compléter
ce qui est actuellement prévu en
précisant que ces actions et ces
programmes contribuent à réduire les
inégalités territoriales de santé
ces inégalités s'analyse aujourd'hui
comme un véritable frein dans l'accès
aux soins et sa compagne d'après le
rapport remis par monsieur flajolet
d'inégalités territoriales de l'action
sociale dans son ensemble
on ne peut que valider cette réflexion
qui témoigne de ce que nous
non sont les professionnels de santé
suivent le même mouvement d'abandon des
territoires que l'ensemble des services
publics
nous considérons donc que les agences
régionales de santé doivent intégrer la
lutte contre les inégalités
territoriales et sociales comme une
priorité des agences régionales de santé
c'est l'objet de cette annonce
merci l'avis de la commission
défavorable l'avis du gouvernement
défavorable puisque cet amendement
l'objectif de cet amendement est
explicitement couverts par les missions
confiées aux agences régionales de santé
donc c'est une demande de retrait un
avis défavorable non pas sur le fond
mais parce que effectivement il est déjà
satisfait vous maintenez votre
amendement alors je fais voter sur
l'amendement présenté le ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption
ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 1047 ce
monsieur domaine qu'ils présentent
un ministre l'accessibilité des
personnes en situation de handicap dans
la vie ordinaire constitue un des axes
forts du projet de loi pour l'égalité
des droits et des chances la
participation et la citoyenneté des
personnes handicapées
la loi du 11 février 2005 sur lequel de
nombreuses associations se sont
mobilisées afin que ce principe ne reste
pas lettre morte faute de nombreuses
dérogations
la loi du 11 février 2005 prévoit dans
son article 45 que la chaîne du
déplacement qui comprend le cadre bâti
la voirie les aménagements des espaces
publics des systèmes de transport et
leur intermodalité est organisé pour
permettre son accessibilité dans sa
totalité aux personnes handicapées ou à
mobilité réduite
concernant le caveau bâti plus
précisément l'article 41 stipule qu'une
collectivité publique ne peut accorder
une subvention pour la construction
l'extension et transformation du gros
oeuvre d'un bâtiment que si le maître
d'ouvragé a produit un dossier relatif à
l'accessibilité
cet amendement s'inscrit dans une
démarche de responsabilisation des ars
afin qu'elles soient chargées de veiller
à la mise en accessibilité des lieux de
soins de dépistage de prévention ainsi
que des établissements médico sociaux
car en effet si aujourd'hui l'accès aux
soins spécifiques des personnes en
situation de handicap est en partie
assuré en france ce n'est souvent pas le
cas ni des soins courants ni des actions
dépistage de prévention est pourtant
d'une ligne or la morbidité la mortalité
de ces personnes sont plus élevées que
celle de la population générale
non seulement du fait de leur handicap
qui les prédisposent à un risque plus
élevé de pathologie mais également du
fait d'une prise en charge médicale
soient insuffisantes ou inadéquates
ces problèmes d'accès aux soins nous
faisons d'ailleurs que s'accroître
lorsque les personnes sont
polyhandicapés et handicapées mentales
parce que l'accès aux soins primaires et
préventif et à des enjeux majeurs de
l'égalité des chances
c'est un moment vous propose d'apporter
une réponse à une des causes identifiées
de cette inégalité l'inaccessibilité
physique des structures aux personnes en
perte d'autonomie ou en situation de
handicap
merci monsieur le maine l'avis de la
commission
la commission a considéré que
cet amendement était satisfait puisque
la loi du 11 février 2005 a prévu les
obligations en la matière et leurs
conditions d'application dont elle
demande à rentrer et où l avis
défavorable à vis du gouvernement madame
le ministre
mais ma vie madame la présidente pour
les mêmes motifs en fait la loi du 11
février 2005 prévoit toutes les
conditions nécessaires aujourd'hui pour
faire appliquer la loi pleinement y
compris dans les établissements médicaux
et médico sociaux merci monsieur le
maine bah écoutez je m'accepte longueur
dont je retire mon amendement
merci l'amendement 1048 que présente que
des formations patients
madame la présidente mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à compléter
l'article 26 tu par un alinéa ainsi
rédigé dans les départements régions
d'outre-mer les agences régionales de
santé organise l'offre de soins au
niveau régional dans les conditions
définies par la loi
en effet mes chers collègues dans les
départements régions d'outre-mer compte
tenu de l' isolement de ces territoires
par rapport à l'hexagone
il est urgent d'aider au développement
et renforcement de la coopération
interrégionale l'offre de soins à
l'échelle interrégionale est un élément
primordial à mettre en place le concept
de mutualisation et de complémentarité
sont incontournables pour améliorer
l'offre de soins afin de s'inscrire dans
une logique de santé publique
or cette coopération est difficilement
réalisable compte tenu des situations
géographiques de ces territoires par
exemple dans la zone antilles guyane les
transferts vers les structures les plus
proches se situent au mieux à deux
heures d'avion
sinon à une journée d' avion lorsque les
compétences requises sont absentes
et quand il y à un avion la mise en
place du schéma interrégional
d'organisation sanitaire de la zone
antilles guyane est un passé non
négligeable qui témoigne de cette
volonté de coopération et de souci de
qualité apportée aux populations de ce
département
mais elle est insuffisante l'acceptation
de cet amendement permettra à l'état
d'adopter les dispositions
indispensables à la réalisation de ces
coopération afin que ces départements
régions deviennent autonomes sur le plan
sanitaire et puisse ainsi offrir un
panel de soins complets merci ans chaque
collègue l'avis de la commission
même la présidente de l'amendement note
que la satisfait par les dispositions
figurant l'article suivant vie de
du gouvernement madame le ministre oui
effectivement un avis défavorable
c'est vrai que la situation particulière
de nos concitoyens ultramarins doit leur
permettre d'avoir une offre de soins de
proximité de relative proximité surtout
évidemment une offre de soins de qualité
mais la loi n'est pas requise pour pour
cette mise en oeuvre
c'est une démarche de dire que nous
avons déjà largement amorcée et les
agences régionales de santé ont pour
mission d'approfondir ces démarches
inter régionale il faut en plus convenir
qu'il faut aussi approfondir les
coopérations avec les départements et
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
lors de la discussion de l'article 33
puisque le gouvernement a l'intention de
développer une coopération du type que
vous souhaitez entre la région de la
réunion est le département de mayotte
donc il faut laisser les possibilités et
d'avoir une agence de santé qui serait
commune un département et à une région
donc il faut laisser beaucoup de
souplesse assez coopération
inter-régionale que comme vous je
défends mais je pense que c'est vraiment
pas du niveau législatif qui risquent
plutôt d'émettre un carcan que d'apple
que de privilégier des démarches haddock
sur patient vous maintenez votre
amendement
monsieur désessard demandé la parole
oui mais madame la ministre sera porteur
je voudrais insister effectivement sur
le non seulement sur la spécificité de
l'outre-mer mais également la différence
entre les départements d'outre-mer
est-ce que caen va mayotte effectivement
la proximité là et il ya un grand
hôpital bon mais quand on vend guyane
alors là c'est effectivement pas du tout
la même chose alors je sais que l'on dit
que la guyane c'est la grandeur du
portugal ou de la belgique
on ne sait pas exactement mais enfin
c'est très très grand et donc la
question se pose de façon cruciale et
donc il faut tenir compte de cette
spécificité des moyens qu'il faut donner
par rapport à un département comme la
guyane ou alors ça veut dire qu'on n'en
tient pas compte réellement ok on prend
des mesures générales les mesures
générales elles doivent bien avoir des
caractéristiques particulières par
rapport à départements comme la guyane
et puisque mots mais mes collègues
guyanais sont là je vous rappelle madame
la ministre
un voyage que vous avez fait il ya un an
ah oui et vous parce que vous êtes allé
en pirogue à atwan qu'est donc et mais
ils connaissent bien mes collègues
guyanais savent les conditions
difficiles des villages amérindiens et
bien me boucher non mais moi je voudrais
surtout madame la ministre que
l'engagement vous avez pris auprès des
des du village amérindien de twenké vous
pourriez qui est la réhabilitation qui
vaut vraiment pas cher du centre médical
de prévention voilà c'était le le dire
une fois vous me dit que vous allez me
donner une réponse positive donc
j'attends cette réponse positive avec
impatience j'espère qu'on finira le
traitement de cette loi avant vendredi
soir donc j'espère que la réponse
positive sera là avant vendredi soir
donc mais j'aurais location l'occasion
de deux
d'appuyer les demandes spécifiques de
mes collègues guyanais compte tenu de
l'immensité du territoire des
difficultés de communication sur
d'autres sujets comme par exemple centre
médical d'apatou et d'autre mais nous
aurons l'occasion de revoir ça alors
d'autres amendements ces patients vous
vouliez dire un mot vous maintenez votre
amendement alors je vais mettre aux voix
cet amendement ceux qui sont favorables
à son adoption lèveront la main ceux qui
sont contre
s'il vous plaît nous allons faire un
vote
assis debout pour ceux qui sont
favorables voudront bien se lever
merci vous pouvez vous asseoir
ceux qui sont contre cet amendement
voudront bien se lever il n'est pas
adopté l'égalité n'est pas adopté vous
venez de suivre
l'examen du projet de loi hôpital
patients santé et territoires tout de
suite le journal de 18h merci de votre
fidélité et à très bientôt sur public
sénat